what's up BTS army what's up guys
we're gonna watch 2020 that's the BTS
Korean words we are bulletproof the
eternal MV sensor music video hashtag
2020
BTS Festa that's what's up
yeah this here is a very beautiful video
and a really deep one as well excited to
check it out it's probably gonna be cut
up just a little bit you might see like
other youtubers who when they do music
video reactions they'll pause and play
and because they're not playing it
consistently throughout it helps to get
it visible on YouTube without it getting
blocked or running into copyright issues
but we don't like doing that pausing and
playing we'd like to absorb the song and
one whole setting so that's why there'll
be a little bit of cuts here and there
also to ensure that this will be visible
on YouTube and not another block BTS
video November 2 patreon John does music
video reactions weekly I'm gonna be
joining him a lot more often over there
we do a lot of uncut music video
reactions over there we also have a
weekly Q&A podcast and TV show reactions
blah blah blah blah blah let's watch
this
[Music]
I love animated videos
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
[Music]
this is freaking beautiful yeah
[Music]
[Music]
we're sailing a whale
haha
[Music]
[Applause]
not seven with you we're army
[Music]
[Music]
Wow I was gorgeous yeah they spent eight
months learning the choreography for
that music video the motion capturing is
it's nice to get a song that is about
distancing yourself from others and that
in order to really survive in the world
don't trust other individuals and that
unity is not the key to it all it's
about you know being individual and
isolating yourself and that the Army is
age seven is the most crucial time to
lock in all these less yes yeah I
thought this was 100 percent just
freaking beautiful obviously the
animation is drop-dead gorgeous
so expression it kind of look like a
like a video that's very like pastel it
felt very tangible and very hand-drawn
yeah I was like you could feel like the
sweeping of the pages which I thought
was just gorgeous but in a day and age
that we're living in now or honestly
that would be a little bit ever such a
long time it's important to have
messages of unity out there we were
talking about action of the video we
react on page around recently and how
they seem to have a very unique
relationship with their fans in the
sense of you know you always hear people
saying like we love our fans and we want
to be here without the fans and for
people like these guys who are on this
massive global scale worldwide
sensations there is this sense that you
really do get from them of how genuine
they are when it comes to their
connection with their fans it's
expressed throughout this whole song you
know like we are not only seven now that
with everyone together you know we are
bulletproof it's like they do a lot of
songs a deal with perseverance self love
there's like a couple of lines that one
can interpret as like because they're
talking about
people throw stones at us and think of
the phrase of that the higher of the
mountain you climb the more arrows are
gonna be on your back things such as
that and in this song talking about
unity that all of us together should be
a thing that is based off of love you
know of course interpreting it this way
but I feel like the nebulous of what I'm
talking about is actually prevalent
throughout the sauna while we have our
struggles together if we can find a
sense of equality and understanding that
is the way we continue to thrive is
based off of that love and endure the
pains that we have in this world so yeah
I thought this was absolutely gorgeous
beautiful when it goes to enhance the
sense of community to like a like you
pointed out with that we are not only
seven we have this kind of big group of
like-minded people who are very
passionate in the sound directions as us
and I feel like in a band in a position
like they are you can feel like seven
people against the world I'm sure and in
that dynamic I'm sure it's easy to feel
like you're not seven people you're a
bunch of individuals we're all bouncing
off of each other so the metaphor I
think goes in different directions but
yeah speaking to that level of community
that comes out of this stuff and also I
thought it was interesting too because
I'm not the expert on this stuff but
looking through the images they're
putting out in this video there are a
lot of settings and a lot of locations
that are drawn here though made me think
back to some of the other BTS videos
I've seen because I know that there are
certain settings that are associated
with certain members of the band and
certain you know plot lines that their
music videos have gone through exploring
things like you know the loss of youth
and innocence and things like that
so I cut echoes of those popping up
throughout this video which I thought
was just a cool thing especially because
you know map of the soul seven is to
commemorate there are seven a year doing
this as well as you know that seven
seems like a very prominent number for
them there's seven piece they've been at
this for seven years now this is the
penultimate song off that album and it
has yeah that very buoyant and ethereal
quality and it's got some Drive it's got
enough of that strength in it to draw
home.the perseverance but without being
as much of a heavy banger as a lot of
times those songs can be it's more about
the sort of emotional swell that that
unity and that perseverance can bring
rather than like the punch you know and
I appreciate that flavor and that
tambour and just the the soundscape and
everything there was really a beautiful
marriage of song and images and for them
especially I mean they are icons they
are our dancers there's a lot of reasons
to put them front and center in the
video and so I appreciated here that
they went with the art style because I
can imagine people wanting the actual
band on the screen but I don't know I
thought what they did here especially
with the visual metaphor isn't even
coming through at the end with the Whale
sailing through the clouds was just
really beautiful yeah and a nice way to
commemorate what I understand to be you
know what this album is about you know
well I think with the animation it kind
of further drives home that point of
loss of innocence you know you might
have a perception of the world but as
you keep growing up perceptions of
things can often be altered and change
and life just seems to get more
difficult as you grow up an animation is
often associated with childhood I know
this is something I'm taking it acid
okay you know so there's a wide variety
of reasons of why they chose the
animation and maybe they have a
clear-cut answer on some behind the
scenes video that I just haven't seen
yet there's a thread online where
somebody breaks down every frame of this
oh yeah you know another phrase that
comes to mind is that like two or three
people with a common purpose nothing is
impossible and that the whole point of
this song of like all of us banding
together for this act of loved' I mean
who's going to the theme of we're
bulletproof that nothing can take us
down and what I appreciate about it it
wasn't like soothing they kept it in
this sort of melancholy tone because
right now we are living in hard times
and it seems to be a worldwide think
that we're acknowledging the sorrows so
the world is the world's acknowledging
the really sad things that are going on
in this world that we're trying to
uproot right now and in a wide variety
of ways and so dealing with the sorrows
I liked how they let this tune when it's
instrumentals and it's chorus still
assemble a bit of that hardship
throughout but still saying that even
when we're feeling down who might not be
like yeah we're tough that we're still
gonna keep on fighting that we're still
gonna keep on moving forward that we're
still gonna keep persevering despite how
difficult that might feel at times to
keep moving because as long as we can
keep picking each other up as long as we
can keep supporting one another we'll be
good it's that cathartic sense of
melancholy yeah and I'm gonna forget
about all these beautiful messages and
t-minus five minutes [ __ ] anger on go
back to the on music video let's go do
some war
alright guys what'd you think of this
animated music video what do you think
of this song what's your interpretation
of these lyrics any deeper meanings that
you might find behind the animated style
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification rather get notified never
got a new YouTube video what last but
not least let's do up Kaldur E&C pinna
coos my buddy i have no idea if you
actually watch like yes or anything
along this kind but out of everyone that
we have to shout out on the patreon page
this month in terms of the messages that
are being conveyed in this music video
in it of itself I feel like right now
you're the one who probably needed the
most not everyone is as honest with me
yeah well let's go have a personal life
but you've been very honest very
vulnerable and no it's been incredibly
challenging and you're doing whatever
you can to keep on moving and I've even
able to see some family members and
connect with some friends but there's
been a lot of losses and a lot of sorrow
in your life as of late but I'm proud of
you for still persevering and for still
doing what you can to be creative and be
involved in activities that helped get
you out of certain moods certain fungus
ways to uplift your spirits just know
you're not alone man you're really not
alone and that you have a lot of love in
your life and that I'm thinking about
you and whenever we talk to each other I
really care about you man so please just
be safe and keep taking care yourself
and I hope you do check this music video
out because you probably is gonna link
your shout out in this video but this is
a song that I think can really help
and I hope that you continue to watch
the Golden Girls that cheer you up my
friend yeah thank you for being a friend